bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à leur première question
cette deuxième vague nous menacent où on
y est je suis désolé je nantes je ne
vous entends pas ah on a peut-être un
petit problème de liaison vous
m'entendez mieux là pardon oui alors
vous non mais voilà par rapport à cette
deuxième vague dont on parle depuis a
longtemps est ce qu'elles nous menacent
encore où on est vraiment de danse mans
moi même alors non nous ne sommes pas
dans une nouvelle vague
nous sommes en fait dans les suites de
la première vague
c'est à dire nous avons connu une
augmentation massive au cours du mois de
mars avril du nombre de contaminations
puis grâce au confinement strict ce
nombre a été réduit massivement et nous
sommes arrivés à un niveau de
circulation du virus relativement bas
néanmoins depuis une quinzaine de jours
nous assistons à un frémissement
de ce nombre de contaminations qui
valent augmentation notamment avec une
augmentation du taux de reproduction
effectif le fameux air 0 qui est passé
au delà de 1 dans au moins neuf régions
en france
alors vous êtes au service réanimation
de lariboisière qu'est ce que vous
constatez en tant que médecin une hausse
des cas une hausse des personnes
hospitalisées à cause du coc vite 19
alors en fait donc nous nous assistons
effectivement à un retour d'un certain
nombre de patients qui ont été
contaminés par le coronavirus à
l'hôpital alors que à partir de mi mai
et tout au long du mois de juin nous
avions quasiment aucune consultation
pour coville 19
nous avons aujourd'hui aux urgences en
moyenne 1 patients par jour et depuis
dix jours nous avons admis dans d'autres
services quatre patients contaminés par
une forme un peu plus grave de covile 19
donc évidemment nous sommes encore très
loin de ce que nous avons connu un mois
de mars avril mai
on sent que la situation bouge un peu
bien sûr l'augmentation que l'on observe
actuellement du nombre de contaminations
pourraient s'accompagner d'une
augmentation des consultations vers
l'hôpital avec un décalage d'une
vingtaine de jours donc ce que l'on
observe aujourd'hui pourrait se
répercuter dans 15 20 jours au niveau
des urgences des hôpitaux
alors pourquoi parce qu'on a des confiné
trop tôt parce qu'on ne respecte pas
assez les east barrière ou parce que
tout simplement le virus continue de
circuler malgré tout comme vous le dites
parce que essentiellement le virus
continue de circuler
d'ailleurs la situation épidémique dans
d'autres pays est beaucoup plus grave
dans l'hémisphère sud le taux de
circulation est extrêmement élevé et
tout ceci laisse craindre une
augmentation plus importante à l'automne
en france alors le confinement a permis
de casser la contamination épidémique
mais bien sûr pas de faire disparaître
le virus et le niveau auquel finalement
ou d' équilibre auquel on va pouvoir
aboutir pour la circulation du virus
dépend essentiellement de la qualité du
respect des mesures barrières par
l'ensemble de la population plus
l'ensemble des personnes notamment les
jeunes respectent les mesures barrières
et le port du masque obligatoire
lorsqu'on ne peut pas effectuer la
distanciation social et plus hauts
niveaux de circulation du virus sera bas
et contenus et permettra à l'hôpital de
soigner sereinement les quelques
patients le gravement affecté alors
c'est une question que se posent
beaucoup de français où vont-ils pouvoir
aller en vacances cet été la france qui
déconseille en tout cas d'aller en
espagne le gouvernement espagnol
on l'a vue qui assure lui être un pays
sûr vous êtes médecin selon vous que
faut-il faire voyez cet été allez
en vacances dans des zones à risque
comme la catalogne manifestement non je
suis désolé j'ai du mal à entendre vos
questions mais ce que j'ai compris c'est
qu'effectivement bien sûr je ne peux pas
conseillé d'aller vers les régions où le
virus circule de façon importante
en tout cas je n'irai pas contre les
recommandations des autorités sanitaires
évidemment il vaut mieux soit resté en
france soit allé dans des zones en
europe où l'épidémie est plutôt
circulent à bas niveau si jamais bien
sûr on est amené pour des raisons
professionnelles ou pour des eaux
familiale à aller dans des zones où le
virus circule à un niveau beaucoup plus
important il faut redoubler de vigilance
notamment suivre strictement les
recommandations sanitaires de la zone en
question
appliquer rigoureusement les
distanciation social porté le masque de
plus le plus souvent possible notamment
de façon très stricte dans les lieux
clos public
et puis bien sûr surtout se faire tester
le 48 heures avant de rentrer en france
pour éviter de ramener le virus est bien
sûr de lancer un foyer épidémique
à son retour alors il ya deux écoles 1
soit on trouve un vaccin manifestement
qui pourra mettre fin à ce virus soit il
faudra vivre justement avec ce virus
comme on vit avec la grippe est ce que
ça pourrait être le cas
mur avec le kobe de 19 h à canet qui
reviendrait alors en fait le coguic 19
comme on l'a vu ne disparaît pas il est
en permanence là simplement son niveau
de circulation varie en fonction de la
période de l'année et en fonction de
tout niveau d'application des mesures
barrières alors beaucoup de progrès ont
été effectués dans la recherche d'un
vaccin efficace
au jour d'aujourd'hui au moins cinq
vaccins candidats sont déjà en phase iii
d'expérimentation c'est à dire on est
administré un nombre extrêmement élevé
de personnes et on va vérifier si en
situation naturelle de vie
eh bien ces personnes vaccinées bon oui
ou non être protégés contre la copie 19
ans qui a beaucoup d'espoir évidemment
que l'on puisse très rapidement mettre
au point un vaccin
ce vaccin devra alors être produit en
très grande quantité et être bien sûr
proposé à l'ensemble des habitants de la
terre en tout cas du moins ceux qui
n'ont pas pour le moment était
contaminée par le comique 19
en fait le vaccin contribuera à la fois
à protéger l'individu vacciner mais
aussi à permettre de d'atteindre une
immunité de la population suffisante
pour arrêter définitivement la
circulation du virus pour ne pas dire le
faire disparaître car là dessus
évidemment c'est un peu plus
hypothétique puisque il est probable
qu'il existe des réservoirs animaux qui
garderait éventuellement ce virus bruno
m'égare ban merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes chef du
service de réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris merci